let's try the four one seven area code
next who's calling today from four one
seven hey David Tyler hey Tyler what's
up okay so this is the 25th anniversary
of FDR's 1944 address to Congress on
where he introduced the second Bill of
Rights and economic Bill of Rights
mm-hmm very of course in June he called
for a 21st century economic Bill of
Rights what do you think about the value
of having an actual declaration of
economic rights that could be committed
to by representatives citizens
organizations as a unifying expression
of what the Democratic Party and
Democrats are supposed to stand for it
would be delightful but it would also be
the type of thing that very rarely
actually makes change happen so that's
my only hesitation I mean I love all
that stuff it's great to put pen to
paper and say this is what we're for and
this is what we believe in but at the
same time it you know show me exactly
how it'll make change happen and I don't
know if it will what do you think would
be the challenges in terms of something
like that actually making a difference
of course we have many of these pledges
throughout history recently the sunrise
movements which there are no fossil fuel
money pledge seems to be having an
impact some pledges have an impact many
of them have absolutely no impact
yeah but yeah this idea of trying to
have something yeah that serves as a
straightforward litmus test there's a
Democratic Party in my mind in no way
has resembled FDR's party in no way
resembles a Nordic model as a Social
Democratic Party right and so what you
know what would be the challenge is
something like this well let's say the
declaration needs to come with
controlling the White House the House of
Representatives in the Senate I mean
that's how you're going to get changed
you you take control you outline your
values and priorities and then you make
it happen and you know it's like the sad
reality is if the Senate is controlled
by Republicans and Democrats sign on and
say this is our vision okay who cares
and it's like I'm not being cynical I'm
just trying to be a
realist here and this is not me saying
oh it's stupid online petition culture
petitions don't matter I'm not saying
that in any way I'm just saying there
are elements of the system that we know
how it is that you change them and we've
got to control the White House the House
of Representatives in the Senate in
order to make it happen right that makes
sense not to me it's important also not
all Democrats in the House and Senate
are on the same page on every issue and
that's another obstacle yeah that's why
I think it would be an upfront litmus
test you know like maybe a way of
creating greater pressure I mean it's
great that Bernie Sanders comes out with
a call for 20% rate Bill of Rights
yeah but he's one candidate and it's one
platform right it's not inviting the
American people it's not inviting other
candidates or the representatives to
Sunim board so that was the thought that
maybe this would be a means of getting a
lot more pressure on Democratic
candidates or incumbents to actually
commit to a common expression of what
their party is supposed to be about yeah
I mean I don't disagree but besides the
practical problem there's also like then
you get people who want to put in stuff
that's a little bit loony and then it's
like then people state shy away from it
and it just becomes its own problem too
but it's an interesting idea I
appreciate the call okay thank you all
right take care